[Music]
we're gonna get into Zelda a little
later in the show because there's a lot
to talk about that game and I don't no
one will ever run out of things talk
about that game for the reasons we like
that game but you know we want to be
fair and talk about all the other things
there on the switch or coming out on the
switch because we share let's be fair
let's be fair let's be fair Zelda's not
the only thing on the switch right now
and it's not the only things coming on
the switch this year thank God we want
to talk about our favorite current or
upcoming Nintendo switch games or most
anticipated upcoming antenna switch
games Callie I'll start with you because
you seem excited will be my first one
one that I cannot wait to play on
switches start a valley it is coming
switch one of the many indie games
nintendo actually has a really
surprising like a surprisingly robust a
selection of indie titles coming up to
nintendo switch sorry Mindy Mindy I'm
stoked to use me off but when i first
played I mean sturdy valley for my
favorite games of 2016 I really loved it
and when I was playing it I just was
always thinking I want to play this in
bed like this is so relaxing and I have
a desk I have a gaming pc so i wasn't
going to play it in bed yeah the first
time i played it was when i had like a
very very high fever and i played it for
like 12 hours and didn't remember any
area looks like she's got a high fever
yeah Mary catch her gamespot me it's
funnier if you know how much she played
this game Mary catch former gamespot
producer played a lot of starter valley
i think was like her number 2 game last
years and it was her first and last
review for us yes yes so just came in
went out with a bang I guess all this
game's not really i explosion i went
home every day for several weeks and
play this and i think in a month i
logged 160 hours which is a lot yeah and
you only need you do them on i went to
work method 80 and i forgot to eat i
actually forgot to eat dinner playing
this game her mom first not no not for
the entire month but i just think it's
the game the gameplay is really suited
to the switch and I'm I know like I
already own this I will buy it again for
switch and if you haven't placed rd
valley yet i think if you have a switch
it might be
really great play split can't guarantee
that though because I don't know if the
control screen is weird but i would say
that might be having it portable and
being able just kind of play a day or
two at a time would be awesome do you
mean you don't know if like it is mapped
well to the switch the control oh yeah i
mean i can't guarantee that which
versions gonna be great the console
versions did have a few controls i guess
if i remember correctly or some other
hiccups there was like a saving problem
on xbox one i'm just i mean so i can't
guarantee anything but i would say this
which is a really good platform to try
it out on and hopefully the touchscreen
helps i think alleviation those issues
yeah especially because when it you know
it's designed for pc inventory
management is much easier with a mouse
and keyboard but yeah I think that's a
good point touch screen will helped you
there was going to be a view to port
back in the day and it was cancelled
right so this is cut back a spiritual
successor to the data force which is
almost a spiritual successor to the PETA
yeah I think yeah in a lot of ways Pete
what a switch game are you or are you
going to be excited about I'm excited
about a few things uh a couple games
which are well one of them is just a
port I am setsuna which was RPG from
Tokyo RPG factory very reminiscent
Chrono Trigger and has sort of like a
very sorrowful story and I started
playing that again the other day and
that game is still good it's still a
good RPG it's not amazing but I'm glad
to have an excuse to maybe play it again
in my off time also fast rmx which is
almost support of fast racing neo from
we but it adds in a few new tracks and
stuff like that that is like a great
amalgamation of conceits from f0 and the
wipeout racing game both two series that
aren't really there's nothing really
coming out and either one of those so
this is like a wonderful little taste of
those types of games there really fast
racing games and I've also been enjoying
from the Japanese eShop which is super
easy to sign into and use ports of neo
geo arcade games these are not under the
Virtual Console umbrella but they are
that just called arcade classics from
hamster Corp who's does a lot of the
same things on playstation 4 call what
your court amster corp okay they've
actually been very successful over the
past couple years like it's kind of a
cool story yeah you've got king of
fighters 98 you got waku waku 7 which is
a more ridiculous fighting game
king of fighters shocktroopers to and
Metal Slug 3 and those are fun to play
like Metal Slug yes the games are fun
and it works really well on switch I
will say the color seems a little bit
washed out where he's kind of strange
but you can kind of get past that the
actions so good yeah Sippie f you have
an itchy put those I recommend it
especially king of fighters 98 mellow
slug those are two really good ones too
because I've never played a king of
fighters game more complex and streets
lighter huge rosters hmm very
interesting sprite work very like
complex shading and backgrounds and
stuff like that cool it's a fun it's a
fun difficult series Sam Farr Sharma the
YouTube Java saying stardew valley was
not cancelled on evita they just kind of
haven't released it yet right so I guess
I don't know maybe I don't know maybe
they'll be funny if like today they're
like yeah we officially canceled it no I
mean that'd be great I'm davita I mean
that game should live wherever they can
yeah Kelly you were talking about tumble
seed yeah so during GDC I did go to an
Indies event and I damn it Bendis damn
message uh yeah and he's helped me
everyone stop there was a big stand up
there were several games there I really
enjoyed playing and stand out for me
with tumble feed which is they describe
it as a rolly roguelike and basically
you're this cute little feet it's
acceptably cute you're so you roll on
this tree branch and you can see it kind
of an action there but it's super super
hard I played it for probably 45 minutes
with Joey and he and I had a lot of
trouble even ascending the mountain so
basically what you're doing is you're
trying to climb up this mountain without
falling into those holes and you have to
manage a lot at once you have to
figuratively and literally balance
everything you're doing there's lots of
different powers and yes you can like
plant a flag and that's your checkpoint
or you can put thorns on your body oh
that was very good timing and I was just
I couldn't stop playing I have so much
fun with it I can't it's coming out in
spring and if you want a full round-up
of Indies from GDC we have a homeless
right now go check that out wait so does
it use like the gyro scoping the eat or
gyro yeah gyro your own the hero yes um
I played just with the the analogues
address just because I it was it would
be way too hard to play with the motion
controls it's one of games it seems kind
of deceivingly simple yeah it looks very
simple it's very charming art and it was
punishingly difficult really yeah ok so
the article you put up has about 13
games you look great and I think there
are 64 like 54 games that they announced
yeah begins so the switch is going to
get a pretty nice injection of stuff
yeah I think that's also to beat us here
right oh yeah most of the stuff they
should was this year there's like snake
path which is a that was very
interesting very interesting platform
where where your ass sneaking at the
slither on so the business really unique
like you don't make you don't like move
and junk you kind of like your way you
like corkscrew our way around things
yes'm you're gonna hate it like a drunk
be after you want to check that out we
have a list of 13 coolest game should
ever heard of and it's not at all all of
the games that are there and so I'm very
excited those are all like soon to
release yes mostly David's geez and it's
also not just Nintendo's which games on
that list but the ones we said we saw a
Celeste which is this really hard
platformer that was awesome and then a
graceful explosion machine which is a
hour cage shooter in that i really like
tim is also gorgeous so fun have you
played snipper clips yet no I want to
play it so bad fun I like a touched it
for like a couple seconds sentiment it's
not not be an impression it keeps coming
up because that's the one that people
are saying it makes good use of the joy
cond at least or kind of shows how you
can play cooperatively with joy cons
yeah yeah and I haven't touched it yet
yeah I have it looks good a friend whose
wife doesn't play a lot of games and
they were up until like 4am playing
together I will snip you no no I think
usually cut like she's out of each other
to then satisfy like objectives like in
a you know it's a wholesome game yeah
very good family game Bomberman you
played it no Rob hammer ease when he
played a little bit a little bit yeah it
look I bomberman 64 was really fun this
is very different
bottom ethical is why like 99 97 now but
here we're looking at bar man we've
established that you don't know years
okay wait no neither clear he's gotten
10 by the way so I was I was right the
second time um yeah you're looking at
Bomberman here right now yeah i just
might of been there's Justin Nick and
chastity playin reviewer adjacent appeal
give it a seven on gamespot it's a good
game for him I think this game requires
a little bit of nostalgia and you know
really understanding what you're getting
yourself into because it's not a really
complex game but it's certainly one of
those things that works great when you
have multiple people to play against
that said there is like a single player
mode with story stuff but from what I've
heard about 12 switch and how it's
supposedly designed to be a party game
but you kind of have to be quiet I Kelly
you were talking about I played it at a
party with a ton of my loudest friends
everyone was drunk and we had to
continually tell each other to shut up
and it basically killed the mood and
then we had to play a baby the one where
you dropped the baby weight and
literally everyone left the room except
the person who had to hold the baby well
I don't want to confront being an adult
I'm out of here yes everyone was like
times before another drink be um and so
there are some games like I think the
milking one you don't need sound and
that is a hit because of the obvious
hahaha giggling that happen rolla
watching rob play is really really good
at wizard game I think I didn't like
whether lo the baseball want suck hate
the baseball one serve the at attendance
was difficult as well because it's like
audio it's a Nintendo stre how that
looks really bored now well how does a
lot yes no yes they're both free you
just have to like really listened for
like the sound the ball makes so if
you're focused on your opponent at all
your kind of like going to lose it was
very fun I think the the only one that's
really good for a party is the soda
shaking one because you have to look in
each other's eyes well you shake the joy
con in a certain manner the camera's not
on us right now but I'm sure you can
imagine and there were a lot of laughs
to be had about that one um I do do you
want to say just speaking of this kind
of the switch stream watching Justin hey
wall
do just dance was the highlight of my
life yes he was talented he jested he
actually like is a good dancer but just
surprised everyone a sweet so we also
it's clear we also wouldn't at the same
party when we were playing once you
switch we eventually switch to just
dance and because we were like well you
know just dance we can like everyone
will be listening to the music going to
tell each other to be quiet and and that
was a much better party game actually
for drunk people what about blaster
master zero people saying it releases
tomorrow people really like that yeah
wait it yeah it's on the Japanese you
shop you can get it now like okay and it
doesn't have any shop is easy to access
yeah you can set you create an account
very easily just set your region to
Japan you kind of its not master Madison
take a lot of this forever though this
chasity and Nick margarita maybe when
you talk like that says you can go to
buy you shop points to spend japanese
store and you look at an email right
away with the code to redeem yeah
blaster master zero is a return to the
classic blaster master formula who have
been a couple of weird sequels for that
game but you sort of you riding a tank
then you can hop out and you're also a
little guy it's very much a nostalgic
game but the cool thing about it that
makes me feel like it's got some promise
it's made by integrates the team that
yes they worked on mighty number nine
but that was not their baby Ezra striker
gun volt is really what they've been
working on the past few years and that
has been amazing not really a spin-off
but like it takes the Mega Man X formula
and runs with it with some new mechanics
super fast platforming great action and
they have they have a good ear for music
as well so I think blaster master zero
though a little stiff might actually
just have some cool elements within it
cool before we wrapped up the segment
Kelly you said you really wanted to talk
about Mario Kart yeah I am very excited
cuz a lot of people didn't notice and i
was talking to people about how excited
i am for mario kart 8 deluxe because it
adds double dash mechanics oh wow
mario kart yea which was like you know
are a lot of people say it's the best
Mario capex yeah I don't have to pick
between waluigi and Mario anymore you
just get both you can get off stop what
you're doing what am i doing look at it
indeed while sweetie all the way
Halloween you Mario laughs um are you
guys you really like waluigi I don't
worry okay oh no I hate Wario Waluigi
mala we did the boy but yeah so that you
can hold two items I want once and
switch presumably switch who's driving
from what I understand and I am so
excited about that and then just to wrap
it up quick to triple-a that we didn't
mention whether a super mario Odyssey
which looks like Grand Theft Auto mixed
with mario 64 which only because city
right does it look like you know how
were lost both of us are Canadian
whenever it looks like the chat will has
a channel i got the Hat with the odd
continued alifann but it's an easy way
for them to like extend the Mario
character some way without actually
introducing a new character for us to do
the Avengers you're gonna the
Helicarrier is going to come down in New
York and Mario's can I have to solve
that yeah nice yeah good and then in
terms of other ship away releases on the
switch I'm missing one gnarly ah oo know
to call that Triple A know the first
party game I guess do you want to talk
about arms how he brought it up Rob I'm
uh yeah all right platoon to what do i
do there was one of my i completely
forgot about it but I eat please regalis
about arms arms is a very quirky sort of
one-on-one fighting game what we're
doing I'm sighs I'm jean-luc yeah I was
with you and John up some footage I'm
pretty pumped this actually I played the
first one a little bit finally like
three months ago I did not own a Wii U
for a long time and I played and I like
shooters a lot and this is a very
inventive franchise I'm excited to bring
in the second one the presentation at
the switch stream was awesome the dude
came on because hosing with a dual
pistol but a lot of people thought this
was just a port but then like oh this is
they're adding a lot of new stuff but
it's a sequel I adore splatoon i hope
that kali makes the reappearance because
i was all excited there's never a
character who have my name um same here
I don't like glasses off Archangel 3371
I think that's what it says high school
is hard enough uh-huh do you play too oh
yeah incredibly a for that I love the
first two Xenoblade games and monolith
soft helped out a little bit with breath
of the wilds open world I hope that like
there's some sort of quid pro quo thing
where a nintendo is going to like give
them a hand cool some department i don't
know i'm probably not going to happen
either way really looking forward to
that one that's good shut up cool and
then arms yes alright awesome so those
are our most anticipated a switch games
come out this year or they're already on
the switch apart from zelda which we're
going to get into shortly Callie I'm
gonna first time I think I have to boot
you off the lobby we're going to bring a
series regular Rob handlery out kinda
wish you didn't have to oh yeah me too
oh I like you more than Rob I like Rob
Roth school right I'll nice what do you
I what are you doing the rest today uh
working on Zelda stuff as I think a lot
of us are not so you get to talk about
Sheldon I'm gonna write about Zelda all
right oh my god yo all right
[Music]